[Musica]
la storia che vi racconto oggi comincio
da tre immagini queste tre immagini
hanno qualcosa in comune le direzioni
del del paese di cirò che la città del
vino
un'immagine del calendario gregoriano
che il calendario che quasi tutto il
mondo utilizza questi noi è stato
introdotto nel 1582 dal papa gregorio e
in questo calendario si introduce un
ritardo di dieci idee di 10 giorni se
togliamo ritardo di 10 giorni rispetto
al calendario precedente il calendario
giuliano e terza immagine e questo parco
un parco astronomico che si trova a
savelli in provincia di crotone kr
cosa hanno in comune queste tre immagini
uno scienziato calabrese medico
matematico astronomo luigi lilio lui è
stato l'ideatore del nostro calendario
calendario gregoriano in pochi lo sanno
è una storia molto misterioso della nota
affascinante che uno studioso direttore
di un istituto di ricerca in chimica che
si trova a firenze del cnr si chiama
francesco vizza lo sta studiando da
alcuni anni per portare alla luce questa
storia misteriosa luigi lilio è nato a
cirò nel 1510 è stato l'ideatore del
calendario gregoriano che porta il nome
del papa che ha voluto questo riforma
semplicemente per mettere d'accordo le
feste religiose con il calendario solare
il parco astronomico di savelli e
intitolato a lui quindi una storia
questa veramente bella secondo me perché
mette insieme il passato il presente e
il futuro dell'astronomia in calabria e
inizia appunto da luigi lilio luigi
lilio ha lavorato al calendario quando
gregorio decide di lavorare a una
riforma del calendario perché diciamo
necessità religiose possiamo dire 13
minuti non stop
mi mancano tredici minuti scusate sto
guardando il time
questa è l'immagine di archivio che si
trova a siena pubblicata non dei lavori
di francesco vizza e vedete il papa a
sinistra davanti a una commissione di
scienziati religiosi che si mettono
insieme e che lavorano per alcuni anni
per trovare la soluzione giusta per
avere un calendario che funzionasse nel
tempo per millenni per milioni di anni
in questa immagine vedete un personaggio
che tiene una bacchetta indica le
costellazioni loro scopo è forse un il
presidente della commissione un
religioso matematico che si chiama
tedesco un gesuita cristoforo clavio e o
forse è il fratello di luigi lilio
perché luigi è già morto però ha
lavorato a questo progetto scientifico
lo ha risolto lo affidato diciamo
antonio suo fratello che lo porta
davanti alla commissione scientifica
davanti al papa
quindi lei una storia un pochino
misterioso però però il lavoro di luigi
lilio viene riconosciuto in acquisti per
esempio quelle di cristoforo clavio nel
2.603 scrive e magari fosse ancora vivo
aloysius lilius che il nome latino di
luigi lilio di ciro o uomo più che degno
di mortalità che fu il principale autore
di una correzione tanto valida e
risplendette sugli altri grazie alle
cose da lui scoperte un lavoro veramente
meticoloso molto importante che poi
adesso oggi in pochi sanno
non sanno che è stato un calabrese che
ha fatto questa riforma del calendario
quello è stata una diciamo un'epoca
d'oro che la scienza che calabrese non
c'è stato solamente luigi lilio ci sono
stati anche altri astronomi calabresi
per esempio giovan battista amico data
cosenza e morto a padova
oppure antonio pal antonio foscarini un
altro scienziato monaco frate che adottò
la la rivoluzione copernicana la diffuse
nei suoi scritti censurate dalla chiesa
perseguitato se volete processato morto
prima che finisse in galera invece
giovan battista amico è stato anche lui
uno di quelli che ha adottato la la
dottrina di copernico quella che è stata
fondata in quell'epoca lì in cui vedeva
non più la terra è l'essere umano al
centro dell'universo ma spostava il
centro verso il sole qualcosa che era
esterno alla la visione umano centrica
dell'universo e oggi giovan battista
amico viene celebrato grazie alla
fondazione di questo planetario che si
trova qui a cosenza e invece per esempio
ci sono altri stati altri personaggi
famosi filosofi e tipo bernadino telesio
pure tanto ma su campanella calabrese
anche loro che hanno introdotto
soprattutto telesio anno diciamo creato
le fondazioni le radici di quello che
poi sarebbe stato il pensiero
scientifico che oggi ancora utilizziamo
e che ha cambiato la cultura di
dell'intera umanità tommaso campanella
anche lui patito la persecuzione
religiosa per le sue idee era stato
considerato un eretico per le sue idee e
perché era un religioso e quindi oggi
possiamo vedere ammirare questo
planetario qui a cosenza voluto da altro
e scienziato calabrese
che si chiama franco piperno un fisico
che ha lavorato all'università della
calabria e questo planetaria che è stato
inaugurato pochi mesi fa e tra i pane
tar i più grandi e tecnologicamente più
avanzati d'italia
il parco astronomico che si trova in
sila che portano nel i vigili li ospita
questo telescopio di 50 centimetri
uno dei più grandi del sud italia che
dedicato alla divulgazione scientifica
ed è stato voluto da un altro scienziato
calabrese nato a savelli che si chiama
filippo frontera professore di fisica
all'università di fermata in questo
immagino lo vedete premiato per un
premio importante che si chiama dedicato
a enrico fermi del 2010
un primo internazionale che viene
organizzato dalla società italiana di
fisica lui nativo di savelli ha voluto
questo progetto realizzato e oggi fa non
solamente divulgazione scientifica ma fa
anche grazie alla collaborazione con il
dipartimento di fisica dell'università
della calabria anche scienza
interessante vi faccio vedere alcune
immagini
stiamo lavorando in collaborazione con i
gestori con leggiamo le organizzazioni
scientifici del telescopio che si
chiamano antonino e brosio e tanto nella
tripodi e questa è un'immagine di una
galassia a spirale
vicino c'è una piccola compagna è simile
alla nostra galassia non abbiamo una
compagna cosa grande me ce ne sono tante
altre piccole galassi che ci girano
intorno questa galassia si chiama
galassia portici e si trova a una
distanza dei 23 milioni di anni luce
questa immagine è fatta telescopiche
savelli è arrivata qui in questi giorni
dopo un viaggio durato 23 23 milioni di
anni è un pochino sfocata perché tedesco
che piccolino rispetto ad altri
telescopi importanti come questo
questo è il telescopio spaziale hubble
il telescopio più famoso nella storia
dell'umanità lanciato nel 1990 in orbita
e ancora oggi lavora per darci delle
immagini bellissime
adesso quindi collaboriamo con i
responsabili scientifici del telescopio
quindi quindi antonino antonella e
facciamo delle immagini importanti
scientificamente che possiamo
interpretare e siamo in collaborazioni
insieme per cercare la parte ottica
delle sorgenti di onde gravitazionali
questo telescopio è coinvolto in un
progetto internazionale
questa è un'immagine diciamo una classe
piuttosto vicina solamente 23 milioni di
anni luce
un'immagine un pochino più recente e
questa non esattamente questa questa è
un'altra galassia a spirale ma immagine
d'archivio è fatta da un telescopio che
si trova negli stati uniti è una
galassia a spirale somiglia anche questo
alla nostra che qualche mese fa
allora questa è una galassia che si
trova a 387 milioni di anni luce di
distanza è un'immagine che ha viaggiato
quasi 400 milioni di anni e nel marzo
del 2019
questa galassia vista da tre scopi di
savelli ha ospitato l'esplosione di una
stella che il nostro telescopi riuscito
a vedere vediamo se riuscite avvertire
dove si trova questa immagine di un
telescopio più grande questa è
l'immagine telescopi in sila la stella
che è scoppiata la vedete indicata dalla
freccia
si tratta di una supernova stella è
molto grande che a un certo punto non
resistono la forza di gravità ed
esplodono ed è stata osservata dal
nostro telescopio
quindi stiamo facendo delle cose
interessanti qui in calabria adesso ma
abbiamo progetti piu grandi per il
futuro
vi faccio vedere una cosa interessante
che in pochi sanno
questa cartina dell'italia quella barra
in basso che vi indica la parte scuro e
un pò più grande parte chiare
popolazioni di piccola indicano
lacrimini la criminalità di criminali
che ci sono spazi per l'italia ma indica
la partecipazione di studenti delle
scuole superiori a un evento
internazionale che si chiama olimpiadi
di astronomia
qui sono gli studenti che hanno
partecipato partecipato alla selezione
nazionale e la calabria è quella che ha
presentato a più studenti in assoluto ma
molti di più delle altre regioni
per esempio se confrontiamo con con la
lombardia la lombardia ha avuto 228
studenti per la selezione nazionale la
calabria 2.800 2487 dieci volte di più
un fatto straordinario che pochi
conoscono che nessuno riesce veramente a
spiegarsi e dei 15 finalisti che hanno
partecipato alle gare internazionali 10
sono della della provincia di reggio
calabria
e questi studenti si sono comportati
benissimo raggiungendo risultati
importanti e non è un fatto di
quell'anno 2018 2017 ha avuto prima nei
risultati simili e in questi ultimi anni
la calabria produce un grandissimo
numero di studenti delle scuole
superiori che si comportano benissimo
alle gare di dedicate alle
mio e perché questo perché ci sono
grande giovani grandi scuole grandi
insegnanti ma anche soprattutto per una
un lavoro di una professoressa delle
scuole superiori che si chiama angela
misiano di reggio calabria
la vetta è qui in un'immagine insieme a
degli studenti un pochino piccoli
rispetto a quelli che lei in genere
prepara da anni le prepara studenti
delle scuole superiori per per formare
al meglio alle olimpiadi di astronomia
anche grazie alla collaborazione
all'aiuto del dipartimento di fisica dei
colleghi quindi una una persona
straordinaria che ha fatto veramente
delle cose importanti non per la
calabria si per la calabria sicuramente
ma per l'italia e per l'estero perché
gran tanti di questi suoi scienziati
questo è un po un approccio scienziata
ancora non è o non lo è veramente queste
persone viaggiano per il mondo e ci
fanno ben comparire in istituti di
ricerca importanti realizzando delle
cose straordinarie
dobbiamo ringraziare persone come lei
perché queste cose sono possibili
la storia che vi ho raccontato è quasi
finita concludo diciamo un amore in modo
veramente positivo questa cartina
dell'italia vi mostra le 17 istituti che
si occupano di ricerca in astrofisica
coordinati dall'istituto nazionale di
astrofisica cioè dall'ina ce ne sono 17
sparsi in tutta italia
però potete notare una cosa che il sud
est dell'italia non è coperto non ci
sono istituti
nonostante la calabria faccia così tanto
per la nazione per i paesi dell'est ero
in qualche modo non non riesce ad essere
riconosciuta da questo punto di vista
con gli istituti che si occupano
attivamente in maniera importante di
ricerca in astrofisica
ma adesso ci siamo
e notizia di qualche mese fa che
l'istituto ci sarà un istituto dell'ina
all'università della calabria e di
questo siamo veramente felici e io sono
sicuro che se luigi giglio fosse vivo
adesso sarebbe molto felice
grazie
[Applauso]